we should all be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
president biden there amid a new surge
of coveted cases a big step in the fight
against the pandemic thank you for
joining us here at noon i'm john langler
today the fda issued emergency use
authorization to pfizer's coveted
anti-viral pill that is to try and help
reduce hospitalizations and deaths as
delta alpharon reports it comes at a
turning point in the pandemic
[Music]
people in independence missouri lined up
in their cars to get tested for covid as
cases surge nationwide i started getting
a sore throat
so i thought well this would be a good
idea in the new york area more than 90
percent of cases are tied to the highly
transmissible omicron variant so we
focus obviously every day on the coveted
crisis on the challenge of omicron and
how we overcome it and we have a lot of
tools to fight back to help with long
lines at covid testing sites the binding
administration will distribute half a
billion at-home covid testing kits
they'll also send military help to
overwhelmed hospitals new cdc data shows
the hospitalization rate among
unvaccinated americans climbed to
67.8 per 100 000 compared to only 3.9
among vaccinated americans if you're not
fully vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and with just days until christmas there
are concerns positive cases may cause
airline labor shortages delta's ceo
asked the cdc to reduce the recommended
quarantine time from 10 days to 5 for
those who are vaccinated we're actively
examining those data now and
doing some modeling analyses to assess
that and we anticipate that we'll have
some updates soon the cdc says the best
way to protect yourself this holiday
season is to get vaccinated and boosted
and make sure those you are with are
also vaccinated and boosted
debra alfarone cbs news washington